uh hello everyone
today i'm going to give a talk about
the redo network deep convolution
networks from the principle of rate
reduction my name is ima from uc
berkeley ecs department
so
today because the talk is only 30
minutes
i have a full version of the talk which
is one hour long english and chinese on
the web in case that you want to need to
know more details about this
presentation
and uh you know in the past in uh 10
years or so we have been fascinated by a
tremendous advance in
deep learning right uh that's brought
tremendous technological advances and uh
but yet uh at a theoretical level many
phenomenas uh brought by deep networks
and deep learning has been a mystery to
us right so and this work is attempt to
give a um sort of a plausible
theoretical framework that we are
able to
interpret or understand what
deep network is straight trying to do
what is the objective of deep networks
and also from that object you will see
that can we actually derive
the architectures the structures and
operators of the networks from very
first principle right principle approach
and really uh understand deep networks
as a full white box instead of a black
box and this opens up many open problems
and theoretical uh algorithmical and
also applications and uh as we'll see
so about you know 10 12 years ago uh
deep networks um really trying to
study the high dimensional data
classification problems right so imagine
you have multiple classes of images and
you that they set some very high
dimension spaces uh millions of pixels
right but each class or objects may be
sitting on a non-dimensional manifold
and deep networks
is trying to
sort of uh
saying try to learn a mapping from those
data multi-model data directly to a
one-hot class labels right so and this
is a very complicated function can be
modeled by multi-layer networks this has
actually
seen a very tremendous success and
in some things is really uh
what's driving the success or popularity
of the network is precisely that it
lumps a lot of issues into this black
box right make the practice of deep
learning uh simple and easy
but um that maybe make the practice easy
but actually make the understanding hard
right unless you you know have a lot a
lot of those components um
mapped into a grouped into a black box
right so one thing how to learn this uh
mapping right um it's very
straightforward right you really want
the output of this function f of x
really match the best with the desired
label of the
of the input image and this across
entropy is one of the most popular
object function people use to to to to
train the neural networks
but uh so despite all this you know
empirical success i mean there's
actually actually quite a few uh
elephants in the room right for example
um from classical theoretical
understanding we know if we choose a
network large enough we actually can fit
arbitrary input output relationships
right including you can even arbitrarily
change the output labels and also even
scramble the pixels and yet the network
still can fit the training data
perfectly
hence uh once you fit the training data
perfectly you really ask yourself the
question then what the um we had the
network have learned
right intrinsically and within the
network statistical geometrically what
the features have been learned
inside the network is really not very
clear and also despite the tremendous
empirical success but
many of the highly engineered networks
actually do not have guaranteed
properties desired properties such as we
want
the classification to roll to be robust
to attacks and so on or even to be uh
the detection to be entirely truly
environment to the location object
actually yet to this day there's still
no therapy guarantee for any of the
networks so in this work we're trying to
shift the study a little bit back a
little bit right instead of trying to
you know uh train a network to fit input
optical relationship we really try to
understand what really the network deep
learning is really trying to learn about
the data so here i mean the question is
that if our data with suman data lines
are no dimension of some manifolds right
and we try to learn mapping and try to
make the map the representation of the
data easy to use we can actually make it
our sort of wish list right so we have
using this
network to memorize the data right but
we would test the network it's much more
compact than the raw data because it's
sort of a parametric model and also but
the original data could be non-linear
disputed in original space and also to
make the use easier right we wanted to
interpolate or extrapolate data we
wanted the representation ids for each
class to be linear right finally for
purpose such as classification we also
want the representation to be highly
discriminative meaning that the the the
representation that says the difference
in your subspace so that represents
different classes will be highly
incoherent to each other right
so this actually constituted as how sort
of desired wish list but how do we make
this precise mathematically right and
what does the deep network play a role
here
so this actually brought up to the sort
of goal what really the reputation uh
what is a good representation at least
in the setting of uh classification
right
so uh here's the three objectives um
they're very natural right meaning that
if the for the images within this is the
same class we wanted the the data the
representation to be highly low
dimensional right they stay close
together and also there are no
dimensional linear subspace
and between classes if images are
sampled between different classes we
want the representation to be highly
incoherent right
finally we also want the representation
for each class to be as diverse as rich
as possible right why is that right
because we for example we want to
classify apple from oranges right we
want to know all information all
characteristic about apple that
differential apple from oranges or other
classes or objects we don't just want
the color right we also want to shape
the the shape of the leaves and so the
texture and so of course right
and the let alone some you know
computers also called apples right so
the the the very popular cross entropy
objective we saw earlier actually do not
have this property right because uh
there's actually recent work from dollar
scoop showing that if you train the
neural network with the cross entropy
you end up with the the features
eventually collapsed to one dimensional
now how do we measure the goodness you
know those are my wish list right the
desired property of what we call the
linear discriminative representation but
what are the how do we actually
set a mathematically quantitative goal
to achieve this
then if we allow to map our original
data to some nonlinear features right so
the there's a there's information
theoretical quantity we can measure for
example if all the features what is the
volume spanned by all the features this
is actually given by this a very
intrinsic measure we call the
redistorsion meaning that if i wanted to
encode my data those matrix subject to
some quantization error epsilon right
and this expression give us the number
of binary bits in order to save the data
a z matrix in the computer right so this
is actually from information theoretical
as in in a
geometric sense you can think about this
actually really measures the volume of
the space spent by all the features uh
with the epsilon ball packed into how
many each of the bulb can be packed into
the volume of the space now imagine your
data also have multiple class right has
some intrinsic structure no dimension
intrinsic structure you really don't
need all the blue balls right you only
need those green balls to pack around
the data so therefore if you're able to
partition your data in a very judicious
way right and then the average number of
volume actually given by this average of
those k classes right
and don't be scared by this this
expression this expression is exactly
the same as this the only that applied
that formula to the individual classes
data belongs to different classes the pi
is just the membership right the point i
the the sample i belongs to class j
so basically this is the average volume
or average number of bits you know for
all the k classes if you partition the
data together
hence you know the the very natural uh
uh objective right is that in order to
group similar things together
essentially push different things apart
we really wanted to
maximize the difference between the the
the space of all the features um and
and the the volume or space for
individual classes right it's very very
simple philosophically right just all
the features should expand as large as
possible because we want different
classes different and we want to
compress all the features belongs to the
same class as small as possible right
you really need the similarity contracts
and this
dissimilarity contrast
the intuitively this quantity looks a
little bit complicated but actually
later i will see that the whole deep
networks come from this
uh interesting uh there's something very
magical about this expression although
it looks complicated but geometrically
it's very very intuitive right so we
really want to say the first term says
if i consider all the data union
together what is the entire space the
span
how many sphere epsilon bar i can pack
into a sphere
into the space
and the second term are precisely if my
data lies on the two lines or two low
dimensional subspaces i only need those
green balls right the number of rainbows
in order to pack the data therefore the
delta r
we call the rate reduction is precisely
the the number of blue balls the the
space in between gets counted by the
epsilon ball
right
so therefore this actually in order to
um obviously see we we actually prefer
right intrinsically you can see the data
in both left and right the data lies on
two lines but we actually kind of prefer
the configuration on the left why
because it's more discriminative right
therefore in order to find if i'm
allowed to map my data right into a
feature space i wanted the difference of
the hole
and with the parts as large as possible
right that's really what we call the
maximize the coating rate reduction the
space of the blue balls right
and once you realize that this is
something you desire right you realize
that in order to compare left and right
correctly or fairly you need the scale
of the ellipsoid and also the sphere at
the same scale hence you need to
normalize the feature the size or scale
of features right hence in the
literature there's a lot of work about
the normalization and so on
finally that although this objective
looks very intuitive you know you know
it's like like as simple as being
counting right but does this actually
serve the purpose remember that the wish
list what we want our representation to
be uh preferred right so turns out
actually under fairly broad conditions
right if you're able to maximize the
re-reduction then the resulting final
optimal configuration of your feature
precisely satisfy the conditions
released earlier right different
the the the the data uh belongs to
different class will be a low
dimensional subspace and also those
subspaces for different classes will be
exactly orthogonal to each other
in addition even the distribution of
features within each subspace will be as
very diverse actually there will be
almost isotropical
right hence this is a sort of like
generalized slogan from aristotle right
the whole is a lot greater than the sum
of the parts but for good representation
the hole is maximally greater than the
sum of the parts
right this actually has a flavor uh you
know that people have been playing with
expansion contraction and so on so forth
so you have heard about the contrastive
learning contractive learning and
actually this is very much gets unified
into the single principle one thing that
one you can do is that uh
you can actually join using this
objective to train your neural networks
right and instead of you know have to
you know to test how good your neural
network in terms of accuracy of
classification here actually you can
look at how good your neural networks by
monitoring three geometrically and
statistically meaningful quantities
right how the total uh coding rate
expand how the individual classes gets
compressed and how the difference grows
and so on and contrasted to cross
entropy right this is on the c510 data
sets and the realistic data sets and the
only everything else is the same the
same data the same the networks the only
difference is the the object function we
replace cross entropy with the read
reduction and here you can see that the
resulting features right are highly
orthogonal
it's very pretty uh very very clean
right yet the the final feature learned
by cross entries actually has a lot of
crosstalk also for each class right and
the the ritual actually encouraged
diversity richness in the features you
can see the pca of each class is
actually quite evenly spread
those subspace is actually all highly
meaningful right you can here we plotted
out the the the the axis of those the
for the bird there's a ten dimensional
subspace right we plotted out those
principal components within each
subspace and the product of the images
that align with each of those principal
components you can see that those
coordinates of the image gets embedded
into the subspace it's highly meaningful
and symmetrical and in addition to that
right so remember that we are no longer
fading the labels uh every single label
given to me just in case the label is 10
20 or 50 percent of the labels are
arbitrarily corrupted right so the
fainting using cross entropy to fit
every label is not a very good idea
yet i mean the the reduction is trying
to learn what's in common fit one
subspace to all the data belongs to the
same class so it's actually uh you know
only compress what can be compressed it
will ignore all the mislabeled data
hence you can see that the the the
feature learned from mcr is highly
robust to actually the corruption of the
labels
now the question is are we actually
happy about this right satisfied yes
maybe it's a little bit right so the
object function becomes a more intrinsic
more interpretable and also even the
features we learned right our own
subspaces and so on they're also more
interpretable and also we saw that
they're also very more robust to
corruptions and labels right for those
things that we're very happy however
how to model this mapping from the
original data to the feature space we
still borrow deep networks right
resonance in this case it's and still
black box does right why do we actually
need a deep network structure and what
are the roles of linear non-linear
operators in the system right in
particularly we use the convolutional
neural networks but to these days nobody
understand why we need a multi-channel
convolution right the question next is
that can we actually uh convert this to
a y box
and the good thing about have a very
clear objective is that we can directly
optimize this right this is a very
sophisticated linear long convex object
function however that let's conduct a
very simple strategy to optimize it
right and suppose we just optimize this
operating function using project
gradient descent right compute the
gradient and do the iteration and of
course everything needs to be normalized
now once you do the computing the
gradient of the object function
something magical happen you actually
notice that the gradient has highly
structured right it's it looks like some
matrix hitting the data and also a p a
multiple linear operator
operating on different pieces of the
data the c
applies to each class
right the gradient actually has this
form expansion term a compression term
and those terms those matrix has this
very particular form right uh if you're
anyone familiar with statistically
recognize they are precisely
e multiply any vector are precisely the
residual
of that vector against all the data
belongs to the same class right it's
actually from this ridge regression
residual of the rich regression because
if you want to expand your data you
maximize the residual or if you want to
compress it in different classes you you
reduce the residual right that's what
the gradient flow is really doing
schematically this is very very
intuitive very very simple right so
remember our goal is try to push our
data into other subspaces right of
course we don't know how to do that
globally but locally we actually can
compute the gradient flow right so to
push the data locally along those
gradient flow eventually there will
converge on the orthogonal subspaces
and this is a
one thing that remember this is
piecewise linear
mapping and for for the pieces
associated with each class we need to
know the group numbers uh the group
members membership but that is the only
given for the training data what about
the data a lot in the training well very
simple we know cz is residual to each
class hence this already allows to build
a classifier right i mean use a softmax
whatever your favorite choice in fact if
your audio feature are in the first
quadrant a positive this can be
approximated by by a renewal network
hence choice of a non-linear operator
you know what the essence is actually
try to approximate this gradient right
there's lots of mystery about it
so once we do this once we conduct this
gradient descent right for my features
uh iteration by iteration if we draw out
the diagram from one intuition to next
you can see that we from the features in
the previous iteration we passed through
linear operators plus identity and
sorted them get them through a
classifier and then aggregate them
together and then normalize them send to
the next layer right so you look at this
optimization procedure i precisely
resemble what people have found
empirically the residual networks right
but there's a big difference right and
later on actually residual network
people find out that if you have a
parallel groups the performance is
better right that's precisely
residential the resemble the meta
structure derived from the rate
reduction
and yes there's something magical about
this right because the whole network is
constructed for in a forward fashion
instead of back propagation
and even the largest network right let's
say the high 1.7 trillion
switch transformer resemble exactly the
same data structure but does this work
yes you can see that this is the input
data really that the network already try
to push you know this initial
configuration will actually push because
squeeze each class and push all the
different classes to orthogonal
subspaces
in reality uh
in practice we also care about the
classifying data that has you know
highly geometric structure for example
images are rotated or translated should
belong to the same equivalent class
right and to the till this day all the
highly trained neural networks are not
actually fully uh
environment right the traditional way is
just to augment your data train the
network
now the question is in our setting this
can be stated very very uh uh
cleanly right we actually just wanted to
map all the translated or rotated image
into the same subspace how do we do that
right then we just can calculate all the
data and then translate it into the same
matrix and compress them together as
soon as you do that you remember
something magical happened right as you
as long as you actually compress all the
uh transformed images or text together
the gradient operator remember the z
channel c channels operator
automatically become convolution this is
very different from we choose
convolution to achieve equivalence here
not only the task of
conflict compression stipulates you need
to use convolution but also tells you
what the convolutions are those values
of the operator
you can also generalize this to
multi-channel uh
signals right for the interest of time
i'll gloria detail but really what if
you have multi-channel uh signals
you you try to compress all the
multi-channel translated or transformed
multi-channel signals all together the
operator the greedy descent operation
automatically become multi-channel
convolution
right this is probably the first time
right multi-channel convolution gets
gets justified why you need to conduct
multi-channel convolution however
computing those operators is not a
picnic right this is a humongous matrix
that you needed to do inverse of right c
is the number of uh channels and the
number of pixels or a number of uh
dimensions of the signal right this is
hormones to invert but actually this is
not that hard first of all this picture
is highly
highly structured right we know that
it's a block circular circular matrix
hence the circular matrix can be
diagonalized in the frequency domain
therefore computing this operator this
greedy descent operator in the frequency
domain is the complexity is dropped from
cubic to linear right this is also again
the first time right we actually
formally proved that convolution neural
networks it's much easier much more
economic to learn to construct in a
frequency domain and you know you know
in nature our visual cortex compute in
the frequency domain and for the first
time we are able to write down a
different network or every single
operator every single parameter as a
black box also as a white box right
actually in the spec spectrum domain for
saving the computation
and also now this is a sort of a
interesting thing right so for the first
time we start to see the elephant in the
room right so that if your task is to
try to map multi-class signals into
orthogonal incoherent subspace then
everything that you saw in the modern
neural networks become a necessary
component they're not that you choose
you try the work it's actually
mathematically necessary sparse coding
really allows you to separate different
classes a deep network is just to
maximize rate reduction right to make
get the configuration better in an
incremental way special computing is
necessary if you really want to save the
computation from cubic to linear
convolution multi-channel conversion
globalization non-linearity they arise
as a necessary component you don't get
to choose them okay you don't get to
even try them and does this work yes it
actually works very very well for the
first time you actually be able to
construct the convolutional networks
right however deep you want right
because every layer is just iteration of
optimization and by the end of the day
the features you learned are going to be
completely available to each other in
fact this is the four features for all
rotated instances not just the augmented
like 10 20. this is on all orientations
10 classes is the same picture
and also the same story for the
translation if you have a now we don't
consider this translator a 5 10
augmented translation no this is on the
entire torus
every single pixel you can translate the
object
onto and the features are absolutely
authoritative to each other
by the way remember that architecture of
the network is no different from all the
other data networks you have been
familiarized with right so if you choose
the the network you choose may not be
optimal right the the forward
constructor for example your channel is
not adequate or the iteration of
optimization may not be adequate but
keep in mind that the architecture you
get is exactly the same
then if you have a training data
additional training data you can always
fine-tune it use backup propagation but
the good thing here you don't have to
start you don't have to choose a network
architecture also you don't have to
randomly initialize your parameters
anymore right the all the parameters are
already automatically initialized by the
forward construction right architectural
values are all constructed for you and
you see tremendous benefits by doing
this
to conclude right today i'll just talk
about right so today actually this this
relies on earlier work right and the the
the principle of compression really
unifies almost all tasks emotionally
clustering unsupervised clustering
supervised classification and even to
learn an optimal representation right
and the deep network just arises as the
the strategy or algorithm to optimize
the reduction this objective
give a very unified and simple
interpretation of deep networks and to
compare a little bit with uh what the
the traditional neural network this
table summarize that right so in the
traditional since the 1940s when the
inception of neural networks right the
practice is always very much the same
you try to fit the input output
relationship with the architecture tried
and tested and the operators are kind of
empirical and in order to achieve
variance you do cnn plus some
augmentation and you randomly initialize
your parameters and you train with back
propagation you get a backlog even after
you're trend
right with highly working network is
still black box what have learned the
reputation inside is still not very
clear right yet the compression approach
is completely opposite right the
objective is clear and the network for
the first time the network is completely
forward computed right and you can fine
tune either forward or backward right
there's nothing special about
propagation once you understand deep
network the origin of it and the whole
network is the pure white box
right this opens up tremendous
problems right on the theoretical front
right and what behavior of this object
function under what condition can
guarantee global optimality and also in
the case that here we talk about learn
reputation with the class labels given
to you what if the class is not known
right we don't know z we don't know the
pi the and how can we learn those
jointly and of course this this work
will only use the most naive gradient
descent to construct networks right
there's a tremendous literature on
optimization tell us how to do more
efficient optimization of the radio
adoption right they give
they definitely give new architectures
right and the people talk about the
transformers turns out there's another
interpretation transformer naturally
from this log determinant
rate reduction uh objective finally that
of course today we talked about the very
simple uh vectorized or uh simple groups
right rotation translation and the real
data we have additional dynamical
graphical structures and how we
generalize to those cases
and but now we know deep network is
really trying to learn low dimensional
structures once we get
able to get hold of those structures we
definitely be able to make neural
network in the future much more robust
and transferable
and also the interesting thing is that
uh you can see that the necessary
characteristic derived from this
principle right the sparse coding
special computing subspace embedding i
already you see that in the nature right
that's how human brain right
the the human visual systems has all the
characteristics if you're interested in
this work this is a list of references
right the trace back about 15 years ago
on clustering classification and
recently we generalized this to deep
networks
and also we share the most of the code
examples and on the github and google
collab you can play with it it's still
very primitive but highly promising we
are still at the very stage of
developing this white box approach so if
you forget everything i said today uh
always remember this slogan right the
deep convolutional network architectures
i'm talking about architectures are
iterative optimization schemes for
compression
it's the architecture not training
neural networks that's a different
optimization problem i'm talking about
layer by layer architecture each layer
is actually solving our optimization
problem yeah thank you very much that's
all